performance and speed is something that
user loved in order for us to see what
our performances we need to look at the
speed report speed report show us how
different request took in our app or
site you may want to track how quickly
the screens for each new level of the
game load or how fast search result have
been brought back to the users page you
could also toggle between different
version of these reports and I'll show
you what to gain from the distribution
and the overlay reports by the way this
report is important enough to be taken
to the dashboard so you could face it on
a daily basis in my last startup we also
send it on a weekly basis so we could
see if and how we improving after each
new version the main metrics that you'll
gain from this report is definitely to
see what is the average load time of
each and every page and here you could
see that I definitely had a problem with
my site at the beginning of last May
when we clicking on the distribution tab
of this page we could definitely see
what is going on in different buckets
and that could help us a lot - and enter
fie problematic sections or buckets in
our site another very important aspect
of this report is to go to them up
overlay it's important because we want
to see how different users around the
globe are using and leveraging our site
what is the global distribution let's
say of the average user timing we could
see here that the darker shades
indicates longer load time this report
can show if your app or site experience
got any issues on particular geographic
regions it's especially important if you
are using city ends or stream content
that depends on a gear location of your
users here for instance you could see
that I clearly got some problems in
Chile and luckily in the States and
Canada and over Europe
quite in a good position